i've been waiting for attack on titan
season 4 episode 6 for
years now not the episode specifically
but what happens in the episode
and i'm sure anyone who's watched it
knows exactly what i'm talking about
it's the moment when aaron cracks the
warhammer titan like a nutcracker right
over
his head and just devours its guts when
i first read this scene years and years
ago it was
absolutely insane and to see it finally
come to life
cg or not was awesome and so this video
is more of a raw reaction i don't have a
script planned here and the editing
might be a bit lazier so i'm sorry for
that but
i just wanted this video to get out as
quickly as possible
because i wanted to see how you guys
felt about this too because
it's really a dream come true to see
this for me for almost any manga reader
i feel like to see
these kinds of moments animated on the
big screen is just
aaron has three titans now he's
essentially monopolized the two titans
with the best fighting abilities out
there
and that's already on top of having the
founding titan in the first place
like the man cannot be stopped at this
point and that's probably the best way
to describe the story going forward
i first read this moment in the manga
years ago when i was still in high
school
and honestly back then reading manga
wasn't even really a hobby of mine
the only two i had been reading at that
point was attack on titan and one piece
both of which were really just ways for
me to continue reading past where the
anime was
i hadn't started any manga that i hadn't
watched the anime of beforehand
i always thought of it as more of a
supplement to the anime at that point
and and now of course i've learned to
love manga in a different way from anime
and honestly there's many manga that i
feel can only be done best in manga form
and so being a basically non-manga
reader at this point
having a moment like this where i was
just completely mind blown
despite the fact that i couldn't watch
it you know there was no audio it wasn't
animated
this was probably one of the turning
points in me growing to love manga
and i still love anime just as much as i
used to but now
manga has taken another special place in
my heart and i feel like this moment
itself is a big part of that
and honestly i don't even know how the
moment came off to anime only watchers
but i do hope that it was just as
incredible as it was when i first read
it
when i first read this scene i think
only season 2 of the anime had come out
by that point
don't quote me on that because i really
don't remember but this is just how i
remember it
and so it was really long ago anime only
watchers didn't even know about the
founding titan by this point
the fact that reiner and berthold were
villains was just revealed like
i really had no one to talk to about
this scene even if i tried explaining it
no one would understand because no one
knew how to transfer titan shifters
any of the lore that's been revealed in
the basement anything like that
and so now that i can really talk about
it see your guys reactions is just
really exciting
and last week in my tiber family video i
really wanted to bring this up but i
knew i couldn't for my anime only
watchers
and i remember one of my subscribers
wanted me to post a video about the new
episode
last week but honestly i feel like it
would pale in comparison to what
happened this week i feel like an
episode last week just wouldn't be
appropriate
because of just how huge what just
happened was
this has kind of been a rant i know and
very unstructured compared to what i
normally put out
but i feel like trying to overanalyze
this situation just wouldn't do it
justice i really don't have anything
more to say other than
look forward to the rest of attack on
titan even though i'd be hard-pressed to
find many moments better than this
the series itself after this episode
gets a lot more in depth into
characters and the ideologies behind
genocide
discrimination and the idea of humanity
repeating itself
and that's about it for me as always
this has been the anime culture corner i
hope you enjoyed the video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses
you